a
[Música]
cómo
el salvador está a las puertas de hacer
el primer país en el mundo en el que el
bitcoin circulará legalmente como moneda
de intercambio junto al dólar sin
embargo una reciente encuesta
universitaria revela que 8 de cada 10
salvadoreños tienen poca o ninguna
confianza en la cripta moneda
principalmente por la falta de
información de cómo se ejecutará o los
posibles riesgos de su uso algunas
organizaciones sindicales han demandado
al congreso la derogación de esta medida
porque puede implicar significativas
amenazas para la economía del país
mientras que expertos en la materia
cuestiona la volatilidad de la cripto
divisa pese a eso el gobierno sigue
trabajando intensamente en promover la
iniciativa que dice beneficiar al país y
está instalando 200 cajeros automáticos
además ha ofrecido el equivalente a 30
dólares en bitcoin a quienes descarguen
el archivo wallet la billetera
electrónica oficial
[Música]
aunque el auge de las cripto monedas no
es nuevo si lo es el hecho de que los
gobiernos comiencen a reconocerlas como
moneda de curso legal el gobierno de
cuba quiere seguir los pasos del
salvador el primer país del mundo en
hacerlo por eso busca reconocerlas y
regular las para efectuar pagos en la
isla la popularidad de estas monedas ha
crecido en cuba' a medida que usar
dólares se ha vuelto más difícil en
parte por el endurecimiento de sanciones
por parte de eeuu los riesgos de este
tipo de activos que hasta ahora son
independientes de cualquier banco
central es que su valor es bastante
volátil y por eso es que preocupa las
autoridades y como se pueden usar para
transacciones a larga distancia son
usadas en ocasiones por quienes quieren
evadir controles gubernamentales 'cuba
específicamente ha dicho que estará muy
vigilante para que estas operaciones no
involucre en actividades ilegales
[Música]
el control de cambio la hiperinflación y
la crisis económica en venezuela han
mermado el poder de compra y ahorros de
los venezolanos que en los últimos años
han encontrado una manera de sortear la
crisis y ahorrar dinero mediante la
minería de cripto monedas con bajos
costos de electricidad crear cripto
monedas es una opción bastante rentable
en venezuela que creó en 2018 un ente
regulador de cripto activos antes de esa
fecha la minería era considerada ilegal
en este país y muchos venezolanos fueron
detenidos y sus máquinas confiscadas hoy
también se registran detenciones pero
por no contar con los registros que
piden el link de regulador venezuela hoy
recibe muchos negocios como forma de
pago bitcoin gas entre otras incluso el
gobierno del presidente nicolás maduro
lanzó en el año 2018 el petró una cripto
moneda vetada por eeuu y tildadas de
estafa por otras plataformas de cambio
según los expertos en lo que va de 2021
se han transado 110 millones de dólares
en pico
[Música]